How about, did you guys see the, uh.
[Inaudible] the basketball.
Player? What's his name? Who did the laugh? The meme.
Uh huh. Uh huh.
Car. We Leonard, by the way, I didn't know.
Here's how much a personality matters in basketball.
I didn't know who he was and apparently he's a superstar player,
but like guys like LeBron, you know, and, and,
and even other guys, Steph Curry, they developed a personality. What's his name?
Kiwi. What
car we Leonard
Kauai, Hawaii. The V.
I'm going to play this Hawaii Leonard laugh.
I'm going to play this laugh for you if you don't know about it,
but Jesus Christ.
Hey.
It sounds like the most insecure JZ of all time.
For yourself. And what would you like people to know about you? Here we go.
Listen. I'm a fun guy.
Obviously. I love the game of basketball. I'm a fun guy. Um, I mean,
it's just more question you have to ask me, um,
in order for me to tell you about myself, look.
Let me tell you something. First of all, before we get into the insecure laugh,
this guy plays basketball. I respect this guy. He doesn't give a about the.
He doesn't have necessarily an outgoing, crazy superstar personality,
but whatever he doesn't need to. He's all about the basketball.
Apparently is one of the best in the game props to this guy,
props this guy also for doing this, they were probably like,
get out there and do the thing they were like,
what do you want people to know about you? And he says, I'm a fun guy.
I'm a fun guy. Every note is the same.
If you're talking and every note is the same dude talking his musical,
you know what I mean? When I'm talking, I go up. I say, oh, this kind of.
And I then go back down and say, Hey man, whatever comes out of it.
No, I don't really, all I'm doing is 7,000. Yeah. Right?
You learn how to say certain stuff as a comedian.
You think about that all the time. You go there,
you talk about this mana and then Baja, everyone laughs. This guy is just like,
I'm a fun guy. Of course, it's not going to work.
You're not going to get people on your side. Personality wise.
Now here is the rest of the.
I just can't give you a whole spiel. How am I going to, um,
in order for me to tell you about myself, I just can't give you a whole spiel.
Oh. In order for me to tell you about myself,
I just can give you the full spiel.
Unless you asked specific questions.
I don't even know where you sitting at.
Oh, um, I mean,
it's just more question you have to ask me, um,
in order for me to tell you about myself, I just can't give you a whole spiel.
I don't even know where you sitting at.
[Inaudible].
In order where you sit in there. I just,
I don't even know where you sit sitting at. That was the best part.
That was the part where you realize, oh, lash my hands of this.
Do you know what I mean? He was just like, you know,
in order to tell you what I'm like, you got to get more specific.
I just can't give you a full spill. I don't even know where you sitting at.
Whoa,
Hey man, you're a robot.
Let's just do that whole thing again. How robotic it is.
How crazy is it to have a personality?
But that's what they said about Steph Curry in the beginning.
And that dude lit it up.
Yourself. And what would you like people to know about you? Um,
first of all, speaking to the mic, I'm a fun guy. Um,
obviously I love the game of basketball. Um, I mean,
there's just more question you have to ask. Um,
in order for me to tell you about myself, I just can't give you a whole spiel.
I don't even know where you sitting at.
I mean, dude.
You got to see the video too. You got to see his mouth, dude. It's weird as.
It looks like a Simpson.
All of a sudden he looks like what he looks like when that guy at, at the drunk,
in the Simpsons burps that when it goes, blah, blah, blah, and all the,
oh,
sick here. Hey man.
Easy. Just say, ah, man, you know what?
You know what it is to this guy's probably, I mean, he's how old is he? Like 24.
Maybe. That's the thing, man. When I was 22, I remember being at,
before I did stand up and before I became a thick skinned individual
because of bombing for so much, like I construction in the house. Sorry,
if you hear it, whatever disrespectful. But um, the, uh,
he's 27 years old when I was 22,
I remember I broke up with a girl, a girl broke up with me, broken my heart.
And then I was like, you know what? I am going to go out. I'm going to go.
My buddy was like, come on, come out. Let's go. Let's go hang out.
We'll we'll go get you. We can talk to some chicks. You know, we'll get you out,
it'll be good. And I'm like, all right, I don't really like going out.
But I go out to this bar, went out to this bar called nix and Beverly Hills.
And it was a party that he knew everybody there.
And I didn't know anybody there. And there was this really cute girl there.
And I thought she looked like Brittany Spears.
And this is back when Brittany Spears was like the hottest, you know, the, the,
the number one to me, the archetype of like, oh my God, the hottest chick ever.
So, uh, so I was like, she was in our conversation. I was like,
what do I say to this girl in my head? I was like, what I do? How do I talk?
And then I would say things. And every time I said something, I was like,
how come these words are coming out of my mouth?
I don't want to sound like this. But every single time she said something,
she'd be like, cool. Well, what else did this and that? And I'd be like,
basically, uh,
it's weird. I was 22. Then I got on stage,
started bombing a lot and then didn't give a about anything.
Oh, ho ho.
That laugh literally sounds more like busting a nut than laughing.
It actually does unbelievable.
The whole spiel. I don't even know where you sitting at.
I want to hang out with that guy and make him laugh all day long. Oh.
Ha ha ha. So funny.